Buen día Ángela contarle primeramente
que las intensas lluvias que sufre la
región sureña de Arequipa provocaron en
la luz del lodo y piedras Esto llevó al
desborde de los ríos majes en las región
de camaná afectando y invadiendo las
viviendas de diversos sectores de la
localidad de Nicolás balcárcel en el
último reporte de defensa civil como
usted lo ha señalado habla de cuarenta
muertos 20 desaparecidos y también
existen centenares de viviendas
afectadas qué es lo que ha ocurrido
dentro de toda esta emergencia hubo un
sector de la población que ante la
venida del lodo y piedras prefirió
ubicar Un refugio en socavones mineros
la zona se caracteriza por ser este
producción Minera se metieron estos
socavones mineros y el lodo y piedras
Los sepultó se señala que hay decenas de
personas que han quedado atrapadas bajo
este alud y están ahí la presidenta Dina
boluarte ha viajado a tempranas horas de
la mañana llevando ayuda humanitaria la
zona es muy agreste y
fuentes de defensa civil señalan que van
a tener una ardua tarea para tratar de
rescatar los heridos que hubiese y
también los cuerpos que han quedado
sepultados Francisco es la única
situación de riesgo en el Perú o también
hay otros lugares
precisamente
el comité de emergencia de operaciones
ante desastres naturales señala que hay
ocho regiones de Perú que están en
situación de alerta la mayoría se
encuentra en esta zona del Sur del Perú
y otros tantos en la selva por otro lado
también se reporta que Lima la región
Lima hay alrededor de seis provincias
que están sufriendo precipitaciones el
servicio nacional de meteorología
hidrología del Perú conocido como senami
ha reportado que se van a producir
precipitaciones con lluvias y va a haber
este actividad que va a activar
quebradas la característica que hay en
el Perú Es que muchos poblados se han
asentado sobre quebradas que son lecho o
caudal de estos deslizamientos que acá
es conocido como huaico Entonces no ha
habido una construcción planificada y
cada vez que hay estas situaciones de
lluvias de tormentas que por lo general
en los meses de enero febrero o marzo
existen estas situaciones ya en años
anteriores han reportado
destrozos de viviendas víctimas y por lo
general como Suele suceder no hay la
planificación y la emergencia se
complica porque hay zonas muy alejadas
no Hay acceso de carreteras en algunas
cosas como esta situación que ha
ocurrido en el sur de Perú y vamos a ver
cómo va ser el desenlace de esta
emergencia